welcome back okay we're talking about
Koopman operator theory and how we can
use data and this Koopman operator to
start finding these representations
these coordinate systems where strongly
nonlinear systems start to look linear
okay so we want to find eigen functions
of the Koopman operator that transform
my system into these good measurements
where the dynamics look linear and then
we can hopefully use those embeddings
for linear estimation prediction control
and analysis we have great tools for
linear systems finding those coordinate
transformations is the hard part okay so
this is part of this series on Koopman
analysis past present and future we're
gonna go into depth on the Koopman
analysis we've we've been talking about
how Koopman can essentially find
representations of nonlinear systems
from data and we're going to dig in now
to this this challenge of
representations okay so at the heart
what modern data-driven Koopman theory
is doing is we're using data and
regression techniques kind of techniques
in machine learning and data science to
find these coordinate transformations
these special measurements of my system
where the dynamics look linear in those
measurements and this is very expensive
and very challenging but if I do it once
once I learn these coordinate
transformations everything afterwards
becomes much simpler okay so this is
almost like an offline computation where
it doesn't matter how hard it is to find
these representations once I found the
representations I've done all of the
hard work and then everything becomes
easy for control and estimation and
prediction after that but finding these
representations is still very
challenging and I want to point to a
really important paper kind of one of
the seminal papers in moving Koopman
theory forward is this extended dynamic
mode decomposition by Matt Williams
Yanis Kevlar Kiedis and Clancy Rowley so
there was this realization so I told you
in the last time dynamic mode
decomposition has been very useful for
approximating the Koopman mode
decomposition for periodic and quasi
periodic systems okay very useful it's
kind of this work
course linear algebra data-driven method
for approximating Koopman and it works
great for periodic and quasi periodic
systems but we've kind of known for a
while that if you have strong transients
or strong nonlinearities intermittent
phenomena regular DMD there's no linear
model that can possibly give my give me
multiple fixed points or you know these
these transient behaviors and so what
these what this paper does is
essentially generalize the idea of
dynamic mode decomposition so instead of
building a regression model the best fit
linear operator from the state X at one
time to the next time what they do is
they augment that state vector with a
bunch of nonlinear measurements so
instead of just X may be x squared X
cubed x to the fourth and so on
maybe cosine of X may be radial basis
functions or Bessel functions so they
take their already big state and they
make it much much bigger and then they
find a best fit linear operator that
advances that entire Augmented state
forward and that gets much closer
sometimes to approximating the Koopman
operator because the Koopman operator
really is in this infinite dimensional
hilbert space so they're moving towards
approximating this hilbert space with
more measurement functions than just
linear measurements of the state itself
very important idea it's set up a lot of
what people are doing now on data-driven
Koopman is really kind of based in the
spirit of extended DMD and they'd showed
this really nice example of it applied
to a Duffing system here you know here's
kind of this this Duffing oscillator
with two potential wells and they
identified these eigenfunctions using
this data-driven method so DMD would
have failed miserably here extended DMD
with enough data and enough training can
potentially fix this now there are some
issues when I build a huge state vector
of augmented states like nonlinear
measurements of my states we possibly
run into issues of overfitting so if I
try to find a best fit linear operator
that advances a trillion non linear
measurements forward I have a trillion
by trillion matrix there's a lot of free
parameters and I can get into massive
overfitting problems
not very careful to cross validate to
cross validate my my results against
test data that wasn't used in the
training and there's also related work
by Frank noe and collaborators on
something called the V AC the vac
variational conformation dynamics I'll
hopefully have a have the acronym
spilled out spelled out later the V AC
the vac method is very closely related
and it builds in this cross validation
to prevent over-fitting okay so I'm
going to talk about essentially another
way that we can prevent overfitting this
is work by Erika Kaiser and this is a
way that we can prevent overfitting by
using sparsity in the regression okay so
this is this is very much related to
extended DMD but what we're going to do
is use sparse sparsity promoting
regression to find eigenfunctions
directly so what the what the extended
DMD method does is it essentially tries
to find this gigantic a matrix that
map's all of my non linear measurements
forward in time but when you look at the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of that
huge matrix oftentimes the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues are spurious if you if
you plot your data in those coordinates
they don't actually look linear even
though you get a linear regression model
and so what we thought was instead of
trying to build this huge square matrix
that has a bunch of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors why don't we just go for
identifying the eigenfunctions directly
the relevant eigenfunctions directly
from data and let's use sparse
regression to prevent overfitting so
we'll have less terms we're identifying
will need less data and will get less
overfitting so we're going to use this
PDE for Koopman eigenfunctions that we
derive last time and essentially what
we're going to do is try to expand this
eigenfunction fee in terms of this
library of candidate functions theta so
each of these is a candidate function
this could be a Taylor series this could
be a Fourier series it could be any you
know radial basis functions whatever you
like we're going to try to expand our
eigenfunction fee as a sum of these
basis functions theta and in particular
we're going to want this these
coefficients to be spark
we want as few of these library elements
as possible for my eigenfunction so we
want we have a basis of possible
candidate functions for the
eigenfunction but i only want to pick a
few of them and add up a linear
combination to approximate my
eigenfunction so this is related to the
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics we're going to use the same
sparse regression to find eigenfunctions
you can if you have trajectories of data
you can evaluate this on trajectories of
data like this so x at time 1 x at time
2 and so on and you can also evaluate
this kind of chain rule derivative term
I call this gamma xx dot you can
evaluate this on data as well and then
once you have those two matrices you can
essentially solve for the sparse vector
C in the null space of this operator and
that will be a good approximation for
these the coefficients of these Koopman
eigen functions now it turns out this is
hard to do and you have to kind of know
lambda ahead of time but what we found
time and time again is that if you have
Augen functions with that are lightly
damped meaning that the the real part of
this is small nearly zero
these lightly damped eigenfunctions
persist in the data for a long time
those are the easiest to pull out with
this regression and fortunately those
are the ones that actually matter the
most for prediction estimation and
control because these lightly damped
systems are the ones that are going to
stick around the longest and those are
the ones you're gonna have to control so
for example total energy like a
conserved quantity like energy or
angular momentum is going to be one of
these Koopman eigen functions with
lambda 0 and Orick has been able to find
lots of those conserved quantities from
data using this sparse framework and
then you develop control loss for that
ok so this is related to in
discrete-time if you write this in the
discrete-time formalism you essentially
recover the vac or the extended DMD so
the vac method of no e and and new ski
in 2013 or the extended DMD method of
Williams Kevlar cheetahs in Raleigh 2015
is basically kind of are this sparse
identification in discrete-time and so
you can essentially get spar
back or sparse EDM D models as well but
we're really trying to identify
eigenfunctions directly instead of these
big linear operators okay and this is a
flow chart that Erika made that
essentially illustrates the the pipeline
so you have some unknown dynamical
system in this case the Duffing
oscillator which is a Hamiltonian
conserved system if you don't have
damping we collect a bunch of data and
we build these matrices theta and gamma
here and you try to find the sparse
vector of coefficients that satisfies
this equation this generator function
and when you find that you discover that
there is a conserved quantity at Koopman
eigenfunction at lambda 0 that is
corresponding to the actual Hamiltonian
of the system so that's kind of cool you
can discover things like conserved
quantities from the data which happen to
be Koopman eigenfunctions and you can
also discover more general lightly
damped eigenfunctions just using this
kind of sparse identification of
eigenfunctions ok and again it's based
on the sparse regression down here ok so
I want to also point out you can use
deep neural networks to represent these
eigenfunctions so this is work by
Bethany lush Nathan cuts in myself you
can read about it on the archive we're
not the only ones by any means there are
a lot of groups working on using neural
networks to find Koopman eigenfunctions
and essentially what what many of us
what many of these different approaches
are doing is taking this basic auto
encoder Network structure where you try
to find some some intrinsic or latent
variable coordinates that parameterize
your dynamics and then you essentially
enforce that in those coordinates you
need to be advancing forward in time
with a linear dynamical system so it's
basically an auto encoder network with a
little bit more constraint so that what
you get out of this trained auto encoder
are eigenfunctions fee and the inverse
of those eigen functions that map you
back to the real state space so really
interesting work we'll talk about this
more with continuous spectrum systems
but remember what we're talking about is
how challenging it is to find
representations of eigenfunctions we're
trying to find eigen functions we're
trying to represent them in some basis
that's what Edie MD does that's what the
sparse eigenfunctions does
increasingly when I say I have a problem
that's hard to represent and I have a
lot of data you should be thinking
neural networks neural networks are
amazing at representing complex
functions if you have a lot of data so
this is only going to increase in
usefulness in the future with more data
and more powerful networks we're going
to be discovering these eigenfunctions
using neural networks okay and here's
some related work lots of great work out
there I mean this isn't complete so
every couple of months new papers come
out on using deep learning for Koopmans
so it's a really rapid field very
exciting I think lots of people have
independently recognized that we have a
hard representation problem and that's
exactly what neural networks are good
for ok so the last picture I want to
draw is really how we think about this
representation problem of Koopman
eigenfunctions with error and complexity
ok
so what we want is a good model of a
Koopman eigenfunction and we want the
lowest complexity possible that has good
error so the the analytic Koopman
operator theory lives kind of way over
here on the right where it's an infinite
dimensional representation I have these
arbitrarily complex eigen functions but
they're perfect at linearizing my
dynamical system so this is kind of your
unicorn Koopman eigenfunction out here
it theoretically exists but we have a
very hard time approximating and
representing it with data and computers
ok so we want to move over here and be
in this lower left corner of complexity
and error the DMD now if I have a
periodic system the error will be very
good but the generalizability might not
be but if I have kind of a transient
intermittent or chaotic system it's very
low complexity it's an actual linear
model but it has pretty high
generalizability error especially for
chaotic and transient systems and so the
worst case scenario would be if there's
just a line of models from DMD to
Koopman where I don't really get any
beneficial trade-off as I add complexity
I get a little bit better error what we
in fact hope is that the curve looks
more like this so that there's some
sweet spot here where we get a pretty
good model and also very low
complexity so this is kind of a
trade-off a compromise where it's not
perfect error but it's also much less
complex to represent than the full-blown
Koopman so we want to find models that
live here now increasingly we're using
things like EDM D this extended DMD or
neural networks to try to represent
these these kind of very complicated
Koopman eigenfunctions and I want to
make an extremely important point if you
just measure error based on your
training data I can get an arbitrarily
good neural network or EDM D model that
matches the error on my training set I
can get like perfect error but if I
cross validate so if I hold out some of
my data if I try if I have some some new
trajectories that I didn't use to train
those are my test data and I then
validate those neural network models or
cross validate those neural network
models or EDM D models
I might actually find that I have
terrible error on the cross validation
because I over fit and this is extremely
important you have to be aware of cross
validated error the fact that you can
massively overfit these models because
you have so many pre parameters you can
perfectly fit your data you have to
cross validate you will get garbage
models if you don't cross validate and
so what you have to do is cross validate
your models and if you do that you can
find these great great models these vac
EDM D this sparse identification or deep
learning models that have this kind of
optimal trade-off of complexity versus
error what's known as parsimony but you
have to cross validate your models okay
so all of these methods are very valid
if you cross validate so the sparse
cronic method builds in a sparsity
promoting regularizer so it's kind of
parsimonious by construction it penalize
--is the number of terms your deep
Koopman and EDM d and vac have to have
this cross validated error metric to fit
for model selection and one of the
things I really like about the vac
method the V AC method is that it
actually there's a vac score that
essentially is this cross validated
error score for your model and so you
can use this to select the most part
ammonia's models I think that's really
useful but this is where we're trying to
go we're trying to find these these low
complexity or medium complexity
representations with good error that
embed my nonlinear dynamics and a linear
framework okay we'll talk more about
what we can do with these for control
and for kind of nasty chaotic
intermittent systems later thank you